what is the best way to find the square
of 53 is it by multiplying 53 with 53
traditionally or is it by using the base
technique we had seen previously guess
what
there's the quicker way to find the
square of numbers rather close to 50
first we simply subtract 50 from that
number so we have 53 minus 50 the
difference is 3 after we find the
difference we make a partition on the
left we just add this difference to 25
so we write 25 plus 3 on the left if the
number is close to 50 this number here
will always be 25 on the right we square
the difference it will be 3 squared and
what about the number of digits on the
right in this method we will always have
two digits on the right 25 plus 3 is 28
and 3 squared is 9 but as we need to
have two digits on the right we write 9
as 0 950 three squared is 2809 that
computation was at warp speed difference
of the number and 50 sum of 25 and the
difference on the left and square of the
difference on the right just three steps
and we have our answer
should we try another one quickly why
not remember we are looking at squaring
numbers close to 50 so let's try 48
squared the first step was to subtract
50 from the number that would be 48
minus 50 it will equal minus 2 once this
is done we make a partition on the left
we add 25 with this difference that will
equal 25 minus 2 and on the right we
square the difference it will be minus 2
squared on the right and in this method
we will always have two digits on the
right 25 minus 2 is 23 and minus 2
squared is 4 which would be written as 0
4 find the difference add that
difference with 25 and square that
difference
this method kind of works with numbers
that lie between 30 and 70 but works
best when the numbers are very close to
50 but do you know the logic behind this
technique let's understand it
any number which is close to 50 can be
written as 50 plus X where X can take a
positive or a negative value and we are
squaring this number we know the
identity a plus B the whole squared is
equal to a squared plus 2 a B plus B
square here 50 squared will be 2500 2
times 50 times X will equal 100 X and
squaring X will give us x squared now if
you look at the first two terms you will
see that 100 is common to both of them
so we take the common term 100 out and
we will have 25 plus X in brackets 100
times 25 is 2500 and 100 times X is 100
X and we add x squared to it how do we
interpret this product the answer will
be something like 25 plus X 0 0 and to
this we're adding x squared and X is
nothing but the difference if we want to
find 52 squared X will be 2 so we will
have 2 7 0 0 on top and 2 squared under
it this will give us 2704 as the answer
does that explain the logic of partition
do is the difference here we're adding
25 to the difference we're squaring the
difference on the right and we will have
two digits on the right because of these
two zeros here so that's the logic
behind the shortcut for squaring numbers
that are close to 15
you